hello what welcome to this video playing
Shalimar again and I'm just recently has
an opponent and we've got the bank oh
yeah those side lines are a little bit
worrisome for me because I just don't
know them yeah okay so I'm taking this
is probably not the most principled way
of doing it yeah I've played these kind
of setups myself with white and i always
think 'what is a little bit better so
so so I see going with this and so here
my tix he wants to go on and wants to go
Pepsi three somehow it seems okay hmm
can put it on before I don't know if
this is really doing that much to be
perfectly honest but let's go for it
okay so i've got some pressure on d5
p.m. so each five is not easy play dat I
still feel I should stop this make sure
it absolutely does not happen so it's
coming with Eve with f4 maybe it's not
not so clear when I come on two players
here c4 c4 93 would be good but a five
and see for a five
a five-year him yeah Jamie this is not
that tight ones don't like to give Abby
file but uh huh and okay
let's cover this night on d3 also has a
look at e 5 which is quite important and
I thought night takes a for now let's do
it yeah I can he can maybe get this
exchange but I don't really mind the
question is how to take it with this
maybe check
the sea pawn and the night say I kind of
they are troublesome for what I think
maybe I'm misjudging it but I think ya
can go to see three but after that kind
of surprised that he doesn't take one of
aid interesting it's interesting
you
okay Queenie seven he will just move it
anyway the King I mean
okay this quincy for then it's not
possible
ok
and maybe night f5 as a cool reply I
wanted to go Rupe g7 here and night at
five that's a great move I my shoot I
didn't see that one coming I don't mind
to give up the exchange but not at five
just went immediately for that okay
while g5 looks extremely terrible yeah
after look to 795 losers very nice than
very nice play by white
now you can take 25 that that's it's
going to win just far too much
yeah whatever hey that also wins for
sure okay check I didn't see that one
hang that one hangs ok may I have some
Queen a black hole to play ok but I
enough now look at it not now
Megan win whatever Queen of aid check
black resign I I relied on this night
OMG seven didn't work Jim there this is
very tough I mean very tough position
might be five this is this is an
interesting interesting play here I can
also take with the other night I know
you and f5 which is interesting very
interesting took a long time for that I
think I would have just taken but this
is very strong very strong yeah the
problem is um yeah Queen g4 is dangerous
and here i don't have this move because
of 95 I didn't see that before hand when
i played Rugare seven and gap it's
probably losing now the engine wants to
play look aged seven check and since
this is just slightly better for wider
this is why engines are so strong yeah I
mean ok now the evaluation goes up for
why I think that it should be some kind
of win I don't really believe in this
King position mmm yeah that looks strong
a strong play problem this is I kind of
have to the computer wants to take with
this check but I can go here
this is a mess it's probably better for
wine yeah I think you played that well
what can you do yeah a5 is a move I
didn't like so much I would I wanted to
go see for he of course but a five is
the problem and you kind of have to go
for that the computer wants to go e5 in
this position that's not something I
thought of maybe you can I mean here
this is looking weak but this is not
well placed and a half knight c6
possibly yeah this is actually kind of
okay that's interesting i didn't think
about that at all okay well thanks for
watching guys